les hommes revo se rêvait joueur de
handball un sport qu'il ne peut pas
pratiquer car il est non voyant à cause
de son handicap il l'imaginé donc pas
participer un jour à un court de tennis
j'ai fait l'initiation je pense est
clairement pas me marrer et en fait ça a
été l'un verse et je suis revenue le
lendemain et depuis je reviens tous les
vendredis donc voilà c'est en fait ça
m'a plu et c'est sympa des marquages en
relief et des grelots incrusté dans les
vals permettent au jeune homme de se
repérer son entraîneuse a dû revoir ses
méthodes d'apprentissage
les bailleurs alors là en face de toi il
faut être vraiment clair au niveau du
discours lui donner des repères au
niveau du cou de enfin au niveau des
membres de son corps pour qu'ils
puissent savoir où est ce qui l'a frappé
voilà lui donnait vraiment des repères
le centre jules ferry tennis est le
premier club du loiret à proposer cette
activité en échangeant avec d'autres
déficients visuels puisqu'il ya deux
clous deux autres clubs dans dans la
région assure vineuil et un ce retour on
s'aperçoit que les déficients visuels
trouve beaucoup d'intérêt dans le cadre
de l'activité sportive est aussi dans le
cadre de leur quotidien
parce que ça leur favorise le
déplacement ça leur a réservé au rize le
repérage donc plein de petites choses
qui vont les aider dans leur quotidien
et puis le tennis qui reste une activité
sportive ludique le bis président espère
voir de nouveaux adhérents dans les
prochains mois plusieurs autres
malvoyants se sont déjà montrés
intéressés